all right we're gonna send Chris off
into his four-day weekend with an
addition of PFT ot although he's also
doing Chris Sims unbuttoned later today
but I don't have any involvement with
that so if I don't have any involvement
with it it doesn't exist PFT ot does
exist and Sims is here before detox to
retox to untuck story talks to detox and
back and forth we go let's talk about
something that has come up recently as
it relates to members of the Detroit
Lions organization who are speaking out
in favor of their head coach Matt
Patricia entering a critical third
season on the job last year owner Martha
Firestone Ford made it clear that even
though she's sticking with both GM Bob
Quinn and coach Matt Patricia things
have got to change
you had Darius slay who got traded out
of town had some choice words from a
Patricia as he exited Trey flowers and
Danny Amendola who have that Patriot DNA
they date back to Patricia's time in New
England they have come out and support
the way Patricia does things Chris to me
this is very simple you got to get
enough guys in the building who will do
things the way you want them to be done
and you got to win football games or
you're not going to be there long enough
to instill the patriot way the clock
ticks from the moment you walk through
the door the first time when you got a
locker room full of guys then aren't
gonna buy in how do I get rid of these
guys or convert them to my way of
thinking and how do I get guys in here
who already have been converted to my
way of thinking and can I win enough
games before the sand runs out of the
hourglass yeah that's right I mean you
know first off I think that's why you
see an influx again and free agency of
Patriot players there in Detroit whether
that's Doron Hartmann I'd want to you
know Danny Shelton is one and I know I'm
missing
oh yeah Jamie Collins of course because
I think that's the big the big picture
thought there Mike you're right you know
New England and the way they do things
it's not for everyone and especially
sometimes for players like Darius Leigh
and Damon snacks Harrison who got
drafted by teens that the culture was
nothing like New England they could get
away with certain things because they
were star players and you know could
maybe mess up on a little detail here in
there and because they were so good the
old coaching staff didn't care or
whatever it may be
New England hey there's a there's a
reason they draft a certain type of
player through their cycle and Alice
testing and you know behavior pattern
testing and why they get certain guys up
there in free agency you know you you
gotta get guys I got a little bit of
that robot mold than you to play in that
system there's a lot of thinking there's
a lot of rules to adhere to on a
play-by-play basis and then of course
Matt Patricia just ain't gonna kiss
anybody's ass that's not the way things
are done in New England and you know
it's hard for star players especially
who weren't used to it listen we saw
Michael Strahan who we know is like one
of the nicest humans on earth he was
part of a Giants culture where a you're
the man Michael Estrella it doesn't
matter all sudden Tom Coughlin comes in
with that you know Belichick Bill
Parcells cracked the whip and things are
tough around here and he didn't like it
right so then he saw the results to your
point we got to get better results there
in Detroit to where I think more and
more players will buy in and you know I
think that it would the influx of
Patriot players I think that will help
Bob Quinn and a patrician in a big way
and I always laugh a little bit when a
former Bill Belichick assistant goes on
to become a head coach and insists I'm
going to do it my way what that
assistant doesn't realize is your way is
shaped by all those days weeks and
months that you worked with Bill
Belichick and even if you do a few
things differently than Bill you still
are him the DNA is imprinted onto you
whether it's Patricia Brian Flores
anybody that's been there for more than
five or six years is going to be like
Bill Belichick and the thing is if you
don't win your way is going to be so
jarring from the pre-existing culture
because hey look the pre-existing
culture sucked that's why the team hired
you exactly not an easy fix because the
team is not going to be great while it's
going through those growing pains of
adjusting to a different way of doing
things Chris that's why this year so
critical and and that that would be the
worst thing the Lions could do if they
go five and eleven four and twelve
six and ten oh well this experiments of
failure no it's not it just needs more
time to get to the point where you
maximize the benefit of the Patriot way
that's right it takes time it takes time
to accumulate those type of players who
can have that selfless love way about
them and also to build the roster to
where we know up in New England built in
such a way that it's so versatile and we
know it's this malleable game plan week
to week that changes on both sides of
the ball one week you can see the
Patriots ago man look at this they're
only playing one defensive lineman and
five linebackers and do a crazy thing
and then the next week you go man
they're playing five defensive linemen
and only one or two linebackers like it
can change that way and it's not easy to
accumulate that town let alone you know
Mike - what you're saying is that that
culture that is brutal you know having
worked there having known players there
it's just it's not easy and it takes
time to build we saw Belichick it took
them time in New England it took a
little time in Cleveland - so and most
players are not used to that you know
and I'm not trying to talk bad about
Damon snacks Harrison or Darius Leigh
but more times than not fighters like
that they were at college they were the
best players everybody kind of kisses
your butt everything's great and then
you get in the NFL and their first round
or high draft picks and have some
success and everybody kisses your butt
and that's great you know in New England
that never happens you could be the top
ten pick and you come into building and
they're gonna treat you crap or just
like the the 70th guy on the off season
roster and Tom Brady's treated the same
way too and that's just some players
can't handle it at certain points in
their career I think that's what you saw
with Harrison at Darius slay and one of
the problems in today's NFL with a
salary cap and with salary cap
consequences for getting rid of a player
who has bonus money that was previously
paid and would wreak havoc on your cap
you can't just get rid of ten percent of
the roster 15 percent of the roster get
rid of guys who are influential in the
locker room because number one they're
pretty good and number two you are gonna
take a cap hit that maybe you would
rather not
so you have to maybe work with the guys
a little bit see if you can work it out
you maybe would like to persuade a guy
to do things your way you give it a year
or two and then you cut the cord like
the Lions have done but this is a
critical year and it would be a shame if
the Lions do prematurely end this but I
feel like if they don't get at least
within playoff contention they'll have
to make it but if they're not in
contention they're going to yet again
try something else as this Detroit Lions
team and franchise continue what 60
years of mediocrity at the very very
best when you're celebrating the 25 year
anniversary of your last playoff win
that is not a cause for celebration
vatted the fact that you would even
celebrate that it's been 25 years since
you last won a playoff game summarizes
the entirety of the problem in Detroit
Chris doesn't it it does it kind of
speaks volumes to where they're at as a
franchisee you're right
hey we're celebrating 25 years of you
know below mediocrity or just a few
playoff appearances where we couldn't
win a football game or whatever it may
be but it's a huge year yeah I think you
know of course for the GM the head coach
a huge year for Matt Stafford you know
whether he continues to be that guy and
do they want to go into the future with
him or is it time to just kind of make
the change because it's run its course I
don't know there's a lot of questions
there to be answered in Detroit I do
think they have some pieces to be a
contender and when I say contender like
being that playoff conversation I'm with
you you know they went 18 8 or 9 and 7
I'm also with you and the thought that I
would be very careful or hesitant about
changing you know the regime just off of
that you know last year I thought we saw
some really things that I looked at went
man this this Lions teams on the right
track let's not forget they got screwed
over up in Green Bay with some horrible
calls entree flowers Matt Stafford got
hurt they also lost that heartbreaking
game to the Kansas City Chiefs where
they kind of controlled the game and
outplayed them and did that they had a
few moments or games you know
the Arizona Cardinals to start the
season have a big lead let that end up
being a tie so
I think if they could take the next step
to where they can find ways to win those
games you're gonna see a team that I
think you know is competitive and maybe
in that playoff conversation producer
Pete dim elemental oh I'm doing this
like you and I keep screwing it up I'm
just gonna say demo lightest I think
that's a you you've got so no I don't
even know what's right is a question
worse celebration the Lions
commemorating the 25th anniversary of
their last playoff victory or the cults
hanging an AFC finalist banner which
one's worse well the Lions won by far I
mean at least at least the Colts can go
we were in ASC finalists and we won PI
off games or maybe we're a number one a
number two seed and got there I mean
what the hell are you even wasting money
on making a banner or doing something
like that to go huh
we haven't won a game and we haven't won
a playoff game in 25 years let's
celebrate
you know I that makes absolutely no
sense to me at all yeah I mean it's not
something you want to remind people of
that's my problem with it like hey this
is great a it's been 25 years since we
last won a playoff game oh wait it's
been 25 years since we last won a
playoff game nevermind
alright let's answer a couple of
questions real quick from the folks who
have been good to fill us up with just a
few of these some of them can be
repeated some cannot be this one comes
from PFT p.m. Posse an issue from a week
ago that has died down fortunately for
Mike Tomlin how often do you think
coaches GM's owners etcetera hand
players envelopes of cash to help pay
for a BS fine or any number of reasons
we can easily come up with in order to
sneak money to players under a will a
wink nod belch fart arrangement Chris do
you think it happens on a regular basis
that people find ways to give highly
compensated NFL players a little extra
money in an envelope for whatever reason
they may want to do it I don't think
it's a consistent thing I don't I think
it's you know I think there's probably
more than a handful of coaches who have
all done it a few times in their career
but you know it has to be the right
scenario the coaches aren't going to try
to stick up for some free safety who's
like of doing
illegal headshots back you know the wide
receivers over the middle repeatedly and
gonna be like oh here's more money
here's more money here's more money and
I'm going broke paying for your fines no
that does not happen you know it happens
more times than not with a guy like
James Harrison who's a staple of the
team he tried to do something the right
way in which they kind of like respected
like that pipe with James Harrison and
you know the coach is trying to do that
guy a solid to be like hey I respect the
way you played I know you got a penalty
but that's the style and ferociousness I
want you to play within you know I'm
gonna say you know I again it's every
now and then I played eight years in the
NFL I think I saw two or three times in
my career where guys helped out another
guy through a fining system I think that
it's not rampant or commonplace but then
it happens more than we realized and I
fight back to the early days of the
salary Kaplan more often than not teams
were having issues complying with the
spending limit and they were trying to
find ways to funnel cash to players and
how hard is it how hard is it really to
get together a little tiny briefcase
full of cash and kick it under the table
to a guy who's ever gonna know unless
someone is dumb about it and runs their
mouth and a very wise man made the
comment to me this week there are
certain players that you do give an
envelope of cash to and then there's
James Harrison you don't give him an
envelope of cash because the chances of
him ultimately saying something to
someone are fairly significant as he
ultimately did even though it took ten
years good point another question Chris
W wants to know is Damian Williams going
to be relevant this year he was this
Chiefs starting running back and still
is technically Clyde Edwards Hilaire
though arrives in round one is Williams
gonna be relevant this year for Kansas
City Chris I do think so you know and
again you know client Edwards hilarya I
think he'll have the biggest pieces of
pie at the running back position for
that Kansas City Chiefs team I do you
know there's a great thing sir a guy
like Clyde Edwards Hilaire you know the
offense he played for an LSU that Sean
Payton West Coast style offense and he
read it's the same offense so he's gonna
learn this and be like up the speed I
would think pretty quickly but you know
also Damian Williams still has
value hey we saw him in person two years
ago when that Colts playoff game the
divisional round he's impressive he's
got speed he can hit the hole hard he
can run with some power so you know I
think if you got to break down the reps
for me I don't want to say Damian
Williams is not going to be irrelevant I
just think it'll probably be 6040 Clyde
Edwards Hilaire maybe 65 35 and then
maybe an increase as the year goes on
and they go okay Edwards layer has a
really good feel for the offense
whatever it may be he's comfortable he's
out of that rookie way maybe it goes to
70/30 but I don't think Williams will be
irrelevant totally yeah I mean I agree
with you and Brett Veatch has said so we
talked to him in the aftermath of the
draft and they're gonna have basically
both guys that are used but but I'd say
as time goes by and Edwards Hilaire gets
his feet under him and learns the game
and yeah we may see more of him in big
spots than we will Damian Williams who
isn't look he's he's not bad but in that
offense I just feel like that's if you
have to look for a weakness that's one
of the things you point to 498 rushing
yards last year with 90 yards on one
play 408 the rest of the season when and
again it's not like Andy Reid is handing
the ball off over and over and over
again but I just I think that they need
more and it's clear that they agree or
they wouldn't have used a first-round
pick on a running back alright we
doesn't have a huge presence in the pass
game either you know that's that's
that's a big part of it right you know
we want to see a back out of the
backfield like a you know a guy that
Brian Westbrook who we saw for Andy Reid
all those years where you just go man he
can get in space and get open against
anybody and make plays with ball on his
hands after sketch that's a little bit
what they missed with Damian Williams
I'm just sitting here looking at stats
you had 30 receptions for 213 yards last
year I think ultimately when Andy Reid
evaluates his offense he'd like a little
more production of the pass game out of
that position all right one more
question James Dale who's more likely to
win NFL MVP this year in your opinion
Chris Kyler Murry or Carson Wentz Wow
man mmm whoo I think I would feel more
confident about Carson Wentz
I love Cuyler Murray and I think he's
going to make a Hugh have a huge year
this year I just don't know if I think
Arizona being in that division and you
know still in the early stages of kind
of turning around their football team
under the vision of Kliff Kingsbury is
gonna be good enough or competitive
enough to warrant an MVP and we all know
Mike right I mean you got to be on a
really good team to be in the MVP
conversation and I look at Philadelphia
and go I think they've done enough with
the round wins and I still think that
defense can be special to where I mean I
wouldn't be shocked if the Eagles could
go 12 and 4 and he puts up great stats
and is in that MVP conversation yeah you
know it's funny last year for most of
the season he was the guy who stayed
healthy while everyone around him
crumbled because last year I said if he
stays healthy wire-to-wire he's an MVP
candidate but the team around him wasn't
good enough you have to have great play
plus a team that is in the running for
one of the top two seeds and really at
this point it's gonna be the top seed
because only the top seed gets the buy
now folks you you it's it's we have to
wait for the seat I mean we're gonna
talk about MVP all year long but when
the season ends you see who the 1 seeds
are the best player from either the 1
seeds is most likely to be the MVP and
it's gonna be a lot for the Arizona
Cardinals to be the one see but it's
gonna be a lot for the Eagles to be the
1 seed look I think Cuyler Murray is
gonna continue the trend we've seen of
second-year quarterbacks basically
taking the league by storm
mahomes 2018 Lamar Jackson in 2019 and I
think it's going to be Carson second
year for him so it's it's it's it's even
more of a trend makes me feel better
about saying Calamari between the two I
think Murray but I don't think either is
a legitimate or realistic MVP candidate
Chris yeah I don't know if I do either
I'm not so sure about it you know when's
did show the ability to carry a football
team and you're right I mean I think
that they could stay healthy around them
you know I love Murray has probably more
top-end talent I'm not denying that and
I think he can put up some fantastic
yards this year but man
Ram Seahawks and 49ers are scary to have
to play those teams six times and you
know again Arizona's trying to really
kind of put together a team here as we
go I'm excited for both but yeah I guess
I am I'm favoring went a little over
Murray all right that's it for PFT ot
Thursday edition Chris Sims on button
coming up later today maybe we'll do a
PFT p.m. at some point before Memorial
Day weekend begins either way Friday
with big cat PFT live check us out there
and all day long the pro football talk
calm Chris enjoy your detox to retox and
maybe I'll do a little that not quite
the same way similar but very very
different everybody have a great day
welcome have you got them
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports